hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my first agent Carter video hopefully
you guys all survived New Year's I think
it's a bit of a surprise that it shows
premiering this early for those that are
wondering it will premiere next Tuesday
it's basically filling in for shield
while shield is on break so it'll run
for eight episodes then shield comes
back also really awesome news there's a
couple new movie trailers coming in the
next couple weeks there'll be a new
trailer for Avengers 2 or at least a
promo if it's not a full-on trailer
february 12th on ESPN during the
national championship game if you don't
get ESPN don't freak out they'll post it
online there's also the first trailer
for ant-man that's supposed to premiere
sometime in the next couple of weeks
they haven't officially confirmed when
it's possible that they could do that
during agent Carter they could premiere
the ant-man trailer during agent Carter
some time Marvel doesn't really have any
other shows going on in January so
that's just like the logical place to
stick it there have been some rumors
about possible ant-man agent Carter
connections I'll explain that at the end
of this video this is mostly gonna be
agent Carter stuff and I will do
separate videos whenever those trailers
new posts so as you seen Haley Atwell
reprising her role as agent Carter from
the movies
Domonique West is back from the movies
too as Howard Stark but he's only gonna
be in one episode or at least he's only
listed in one episode on IMDB the really
cool new casting the one I'm really
excited about is the real-life Jarvis
like Howard Starks Butler in the
timeline of the movies Tony Stark
eventually whenever he creates the
Jarvis AI uses his voice as the voice
for the AI in the movies it's Paul
Bettany but I think the fact that Paul
Bettany is playing the vision is going
to make watching real-life Jarvis just
super surreal so I'm really interested
to see how that plays out I know there's
a lot of questions about that Paul
Bettany vision how he gets created is it
Ultron does Tony Stark create him I'll
talk about that the next time I post an
Avengers video I'm really enjoying
watching people argue over the vision
though he's gonna be a big point of
contention for the fandom there's gonna
be eight episodes total the first two
episodes they'll air back-to-back though
they haven't said whether or not they're
gonna do a season two or they're
planning that but I think if it's
successful enough they'll consider it
whether or not they move it around in
the schedule January is kind of a
dumping ground for movies and TV it's
like where all the least popular stuff
goes so I'm actually surprised as
they're releasing it this early just to
put this series into context with the
Netflix shows that are going on because
Marvel has so many TV shows that it's
around now all the Netflix shows with
the exception of defenders are getting
13 episodes per season there are a
couple reasons for that you know mostly
scheduling issues and financial issues
Netflix is co-financing the Marvel shows
not in the way it finances Netflix
original series they are paying Disney a
dumptruck of money for the first-run
rights so they have just like a little
extra juice to do some extra episodes
for the Netflix stuff and for those that
are wondering yes they have been talking
about daredevil future season stuff it's
all just been tugging cheek so they'll
probably save any kind of daredevil
season to talk til Comic Con this year I
think ABC and Marvel are gonna take the
wait-and-see approach with agent Carter
though and make if it's really popular
people like it they'll totally do season
2 so just looking at agent Carter really
I think the appeal is more that this is
gonna be a period show more than like a
comic book II Marvel show think like Mad
Men only if Jon were a secret agent
running missions and her off hours this
two-hour premiere next week that's gonna
completely set up what the rules of the
agent Carter universe are gonna be who
the heroes are who the villains are what
the arc of the season is gonna be agents
of shield has laid a little bit of
groundwork and just showing some of the
places and doing some flashbacks like
with the Daniel Whitehall character but
they do have synopsis for the first
couple of episodes episode 1 is called
this is not the end it says Peggy Carter
is contacted by an old acquaintance
Howard Stark of course when he is framed
for unleashing his deadliest weapons and
can trust no one else to help Peggy
clear Starks name he enlists his Butler
Edward Jarvis be at her Beck and call
whether she likes it or not but the risk
is great if caught
agent Carter could be targeted as a
traitor and spend the rest of her days
in prison or worse episode 2 is called
Bridge and Tunnel and it reads Howard
Starks deadliest weapon has fallen into
enemy hands and only agent Carter can
recover it but can she do so before her
undercover mission is discovered by SSR
chief Dooley and agent Thompson those
are the people she works under during
the day episode 3 is called time and
tide that will air in two weeks and the
synopsis reads as agent Carter closes in
on Howard Starks stolen technology
Peggy's secret mission could unravel
when the SSR arrest Jarvis and a secret
is revealed it doesn't say a whole lot
but that's okay I think they just try
not to spoil stuff so I think the funny
takeaway
that all of this like secret-agent stuff
is gonna be on the DL from her bosses
they've really tried to sell that the
idea of Peggy Carter working in a man's
world like and all these promos it kind
of makes all the men on the show sound
like upfront so we'll see how
it goes I'm sure they'll plate as funny
as possible without getting too bigoted
I'm just expecting to see a lot of Mad
Men gender politics stuff well I think
one of the big questions I was like who
are the big villains of the series gonna
be and is gonna have anything to do with
Hydra they spent so much time hammering
Hydra and shield in the last two years
especially through Winter Soldier that
I'm actually kind of looking forward to
having some new villains on the show
although I feel like it's unavoidable
like it's too big of a presence in
what's going on in the world at that
point what I'm really hoping is is
they'll tell the story of how shield was
created Howard Stark was a founding
member of shield in the timeline shield
was founded around 1946 but just to be
clear shield and SSR are two different
organizations SSR was the precursor to
shield but shield was a different
organization established by different
people that just absorbed SSR I know a
lot of you're asking you know how is
this going to tie in with the movies and
the other series are they gonna have
comic-book characters in the show most
of the connection is with shield and
obviously on the show that they actually
featured that like there was that funny
moment with Simmons fangirling over
Peggy Carter so if we do see any like
direct references I think it'll be
mostly to shield stuff and most of the
comic book people around that time would
have been either Hydra people or shield
people early shield people like the
closest thing they had to a hero team at
the time were the Howling Commandos I'm
totally fine with them not trying to
work into Avengers 2 or any of the other
big movies or anything like that
honestly I think that that hurt shield
in its first season like they had that
awesome betrayal plot with the Hydra
stuff and they had to sit on it all year
because it was gonna tie in with winter
soldiers so they had to wait for that
movie imagine how good shield could have
been if they could have done that like
halfway through the season if they could
have done that is like the mid-season
finale I'm not a big fan of stories set
during this period but I totally buy the
premise I totally loved Hayley Atwell
and Marvel does adventure really well so
I think it's gonna be a really fun show
I think the only thing I'm kind of
worried about is the secondary cast like
the supporting characters because it's
not an effects driven show like it's
really gonna lean on its characters that
means if there aren't some like some
really interesting relationships going
on
in the SSR during the daytime stuff and
some really cool character relationships
going on during the secret agent stuff
at night like the shield stuff then is
really gonna be hard to sit through this
series that's why I'm taking a bit of a
wait-and-see approach I mean like I've
committed to doing videos for each of
the episodes good or bad I think
there'll be a lot to talk about so I
mean I'm really interested to see what
ends up happening
I don't think Marvel has quite hit that
oversaturation point when there's just
like too many Marvel shows on at the
same time for everyone to handle at once
I'm actually even curious to see if that
ever ends up happening like if that gets
to be a point when they're just like too
much comic-book stuff on TV so if you
guys want I can totally do a Q&A video
for the first couple of episodes for
agent Carter next week just let me know
in the comments just to explain the
ant-man agent Carter stuff there was a
casting call for someone to be Hayley
Atwell standin on the set of ant-man
whenever they were filming the movie
based on that you know it's possible
they could do a flashback scene with
young Peggy Carter
that's an ant-man not on agent Carter
not on the TV show it doesn't really
explain the connection between Peggy
Carter in the ant-man characters but it
you know given the premise of ant-man
that it's all about Hank Pym stolen
technology it'll probably be tech
related and just for reference ant-man
is being released this summer I know
it's actually really soon
July 17th I'll talk a little bit more
about the ant-man movie whenever I do a
video for that first trailer because I
think it'll be an interesting movie but
they have changed it quite a bit from
when Edgar Wright was working on it so
here's my big question for you guys if
Haley Atwell is gonna be in the ant-man
movie do you think that the agent Carter
show is gonna tie in with ant-man I'm
not expecting it to at least not in a
big way Michael Douglas for instance he
was born in 1944 so Hank Pym assuming
you know same timeline he'd only be like
two years old whenever events on the
show are happening so I am you know I'm
totally okay I'm totally in favor for
the TV show not crossing over with the
movies but just big reminders on the
dates so agent Carter gonna premiere
next Tuesday on the 6th be sure to
subscribe to get everything and if
there's anything specific that you guys
want me to reference some whatever I do
agent Carter videos just let me know
that'll air for 8 weeks till agents of
shield comes back Avengers 2 trailer
coming on February 12th then like his
shield is slowly closing down at season
Avengers 2 is going to air that's May
first daredevil is also supposed to
premiere
sometime around the Avengers to release
they might move the day around by a week
or so and then ant-man in the summer so
a lot of fun stuff happening in the next
six months right now if you guys are on
your mobile phone or on your tablet you
can click up here there's new mobile
links you click on it's the same as the
links over here but click here to learn
all about the new daredevil show it's
just kind of like a breakdown of the man
with no fear storyline and click here
for all my other Avengers videos thank
you so much for watching so let's all
high-five I will see you guys tomorrow
you